pound later with charisma and matinee
idol looks Kirk Douglas graced the
silver screen over seven decades he
burst onto the scene in 1946 next
veteran movie star Barbara Stanwyck in
the strange love of young Arthur Ivers
Douglas quickly established himself as a
star and leading man in his own right
earning his first Oscar nomination in
1950 playing a boxer in the champion two
more Oscar nods followed over the next
decade one for playing a producer in
1952 'he's the bad and the beautiful and
another in 1956 playing tortured artist
Vincent van Gogh in lust for life
Douglass's most iconic role came in 1960
playing Spartacus a slave leading revolt
in ancient Rome he also produced the
film and helped end Hollywood's
communist blacklist by insisting writer
Dalton Trumbo receive on-screen credit
Douglass later became patriarch of an
acting dynasty son Michael fought him
and business becoming an oscar-winning
actor and producer in 2003 the pair
along with Michael's son Cameron
appeared in the film it runs in the
family
the veteran actor was a prolific author
as well penning a half-dozen books
including his 1988 autobiography the
Ragman son despite suffering a
debilitating stroke in 1995 Duggars
continued performing in 96 at the age of
80
the actor finally won his first Academy
Award an honorary Oscar and I love all
of you
and